quienes aparecen en la filtraciones
hablan de espionaje ilegal de una
operación en su contra del otro lado lo
señalan especialmente a los funcionarios
del poder judicial de haber desarrollado
una actividad incompatible con sus
funciones esa reunión cerca de Bariloche
al lado escondido una una propiedad del
Magnate estadounidense Joe Luis un
hombre cercano al ex presidente Mauricio
macri la realidad es que no está claro
En qué consistió ese encuentro y los
protagonistas tampoco han salido a
explicar exactamente de qué se trató Y
eso Abre a suspicacias bueno el
presidente Alberto Fernández en su
declaración pública en Cadena Nacional
habló de eso habló de que le solicitó al
ministro de Justicia que avanzara con
una acusación con una denuncia a los
protagonistas de este encuentro y de la
filtraciones hay que ver hacia qué lado
va Lo cierto es que hay que recordar que
en Argentina el poder judicial tiene muy
mala imagen y hay algo más Esto se está
dando en el contexto en el que este
martes se conocerá la sentencia
potencial puede ser absolutoria o
condenatoria de la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández de kirchner en la
causa vialidad en la que los acusados
están investigados por asociación
ilícita y defraudación al estado y esta
noticia no hace más que enrarecer aún
más el clima en este momento en
Argentina